yesterday I chaired an emergency local
action committee Gold meeting
specifically to deal with the outbreak
in Leicester unfortunately while cases
in most parts of the country have fallen
since the peak in Leicester they've
continued to rise the seven-day
infection rate in Leicester is a hundred
and thirty five cases per 100,000 people
which is three times higher than the
next highest city Leicester accounts for
around 10 percent of all positive cases
in the country over the past week and
admissions to hospital are between 6 and
10 per day rather than around one a day
at other trusts over the past fortnight
we've already taken action to protect
people in Leicester we deployed four
mobile testing units and extra capacity
of the regional test site we provided
thousands of home testing kits and extra
public health capacity to boost the
local team this afternoon I held a
further meeting with local leaders with
public health England the JBC the local
resilience forum and my clinical
advisors followed by a meeting of the
cross-government kovat Operations
Committee chaired by the Prime Minister
we have agreed further measures to
tackle the outbreak in Leicester first
in addition to the mobile testing units
that I mentioned earlier will send
further testing capability including
opening a walk-in centre anyone in
Leicester with symptoms must come
forward for a test second we will give
extra funding to Leicester and Leicester
show councils to support them to enhance
their communications and ensure those
communications are translated into all
locally relevant languages third through
the councils will ensure support is
available for those who have to self
isolate and fourth will work with the
workplaces that are seen clusters of
cases to implement more stringently the
covert secure guidelines given the
growing outbreak in Leicester
we cannot recommend that the easing of
the Nash
lockdown set to take place on the 4th of
July happens in Leicester having taken
clinical advice on the actions necessary
and discussed them with the local team
in Leicester and Leicester sure we've
made some difficult but important
decisions we've decided that from
tomorrow
non-essential retail will have to close
and as children have been particularly
impacted by this outbreak schools will
also need to close from Thursday staying
open for vulnerable children and
children of critical workers as they did
throughout unfortunately the clinical
advice is that the relaxation of
shielding measures due on the 6th of
July cannot now take place in Leicester
we recommend to people in Leicester stay
at home as much as you can and we
recommend against all but essential
travel to from and within Leicester
we'll monitor closely adherence to
social distancing rules and we'll take
further steps if that's what's necessary
the more people follow the rules the
faster we'll get control of this virus
and get Leicester back to normal
we'll keep all of these local measures
under review and we will not keep them
in place any longer than is necessary
we'll review whether we can release any
measures in two weeks time this these
Leicester specific measures will apply
not just to the City of Leicester but
also to the surrounding conurbation
including for example I'd be versatile
and Glenfield I know that this is a
worrying time for people living in
Leicester and I want you to know that
you have our full support we do not take
these decisions lightly but with the
interests of the people of Leicester in
our hearts